hello everyone story about two videos in
a row but this is one game we simply
cannot miss in the previous video you've
seen how holidays are played with the
white piece against Magnus Carlsen
he didn't fare well against his Berlin
defence but now he has the black piece
against Fabiano Caruana so definitely
not a consolation prize one would hope
for but still you know he had a great
tournament so far and then he faced
Magnus II didn't go all the great but it
was it wasn't that he did anything wrong
it's just that it wasn't enough so let's
see what he prepared for Fabi with the
black pieces and how the game went so
without further ado let's check it out
Fabiana Khurana former World
Championship Challenger opens with d4 we
have Knight to f6 c4 g6 sorry about that
we have Knight to c3 and now Bishop to
g7 the Kings Indian defense is on the
board with E for now the six the main
line in the now h3 Bobby goes for a
McCune of variation which will come in
handy as he is planning on expanding a
lot here so this will prevent fabi's all
it is is pieces mostly the night from
now reaching the g4 square we have
castles by Allah raise up Bishop to e3
and now Knight to c6 with d5 Bobby grabs
more space in the center Knight to e5
and now f4 now the g4 square is taken so
you're not retreating there knight back
to d7 and now g4 so what do you play
here there is one game that to reach
this position but it was a between too
much lower rated opponents I think to
2020 100 where if I was played but here
all it as it goes for c6 and it is as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game on our hands so Bobby continues
developing knight of three we have a
trade in the center C cap for C captures
and now b6 preparing the pinky toe
Adelaide square bishop we've Knights the
d4 by Fabi
now with ideas of maybe going to c6 in
the future
Knight the c5 putting pressure on the
or pawn and now Queen to f3 adding
another defender to the e4 pawn if you
go Knight to c6 doesn't really do all
that much just Queen e8 you still have
to worry about the e4 pawn and it will
only make it easier for black to place
I'm like II 6 to break open the center
since you will not be able to recapture
ores or anything so Queen to f3 by Fabi
and the bishop to b7 and here Fabi went
into a will not a deep thing but a
reasonable one well it is a pretty much
didn't spend any time Ali Reza had like
an hour in 30 minutes on the clock
whereas Fabi had an hour and 13 minutes
and Fabi played g5 so what do you do
here what would you do here well there's
a the option of going in Knights to h5
and night-night here is possible but
then the the two Knights are just
staring at each other not really not
really sure where where the other one is
going and then just H 4 is coming aged 5
and so on so your option is to go Knight
h5 which yes it prevents Fabi from
further expanding on the King side with
h4 h5 but then again you will just
castle and it's well again it's it's
unclear where this night is going this
Knight is now coming to c6 King is
coming to be one if five is coming and
all of the whites moves are are fair you
know very reasonable but instead even
though this is playable Alireza goes for
Knight captures on e4 he gives up a
piece for for a couple of points so
let's see how the game went and Knight
captors on e4 you have to capture if you
don't capture then you just lost well a
crucial point in your pawn chain
so tonight characters on e4 and Bishop
characters on d5 now pinning in the
night and well of course hoping to to
win back the piece so here Bobby finds
Knight to f6 with Czech and now he will
just give a piece back temporarily but
then capture the bishop here he captures
on f6 with Queen captures on d5 and now
rook to e8 attacking fabi's Bishop on e3
so now although you could maybe guard it
with the king and not something you want
to do you allow 94 Czech and also you
will not be able to castle
so you're basically either looking at
Queen back to f3 or night to see
for this for this occasion Bobby decides
for night to see to now the bishop is
guarded and here F captures ng5 Alireza
opens up the bishop diagonal and fob
says okay I'm out of here
there is no point leaving the King in
the center any longer we have queenside
castle which again opens up an attack
against all addresses d6 pawn but ok
Alireza continues grabbing material G
captures on f4 and now you cannot
capture here if you capture back then
Queen f6 comes with an attack here and
also here so it's just game over for
Fabi
so after G captures an F for Bishop to
d4 it's a very important attacker so
Fabi definitely wants to eliminate it
it's a very important attacker and the
defender so Bishop captures on d4 Queen
captures and now the the situation on
the clock is pretty much equalized both
players are now one hour on the clock
and now Knight the e6 defending the f4
pawn and inviting Fabi to grab this
point and now you could capture it and
go into something like Queen f6 which
guards the F pawn prepares to push it
let's say Bishop b5 attacks the rook
rook a d8 pushes the Queen back Queen a3
and now if you don't want to play
something like rook f8 which we which
would be silly you have to react to this
attack somehow probably captures
captures and now you move the rook and
now you have this position Fabi still up
a piece but all it is up for pawns and
he will start pushing his F pawn so if
Abby doesn't doesn't like this idea of
Queen captures and b6 so he goes back
Queen to d2 puts pressure on the f4 pawn
and a laser goes Queen to f6 adds
another defender here connects rooks and
now is ready to bring the rook at the
other look into the game King the b1 and
now rook a to see eight-mile it is up
and now comes Bishop to b5 Fabi develops
the bishop we have root eat the d8 and
now Knight the b4 point is Fabi wants to
bring this night over to d3 from d3 the
knight will use be used as a blockade
against the d6 pawn against the deep one
when it starts marching down the board
and also it will put pressure on the f4
pawn so here we have d5 forcing either
either
asking Fabi to take on d5 or saying I'm
just gonna continue pushing it so what
do you think can you can you can you
capture the d5 pawn I feel free to pause
the video and figure out whether it's
okay to grab this pawn so for those of
you that decided to grab the pawn you
you just lost the game terribly and for
those of you who decided against it
congratulations for you found Knight
captures on d5 and the Queen f5 check
King to a-1 now you capture the night
rook captures Queen captures and then
rook the c1 check this wins the game on
the spot because now after rook captures
the Queen is no longer defended just
Queen captures here and the white lost
the Queen
so of course Bobby did not capture the
pawn fob you and rook H to f1
he puts more pressure on the pawn here
as the night is coming to d3 he wants to
eliminate this pawn and now comes rook
the c5 by Alireza
if Queen to f5 now it is it is possible
to go after the h3 pawn but for example
King 2 a1 Queen captures an h3 now White
has this very nice night the c6 move
which attacks the knight threatens 97th
sorry the rook threatens 97 to pick up
the other rook and well it's just maybe
too much too much to give white and if
97 Knight d4 now attacks the rook again
rook to e7 and now you can capture here
after Queen captures you pick up the f4
pawn and it's well basically you haven't
worn upon you just gave up your very
strong past f4 pawn so instead alavesa
brings another defender to the c5 pawn
and now a 4 that also the bishop is
under attack so Fabi defends it and here
D for all areas are continues pushing
his passport now he has a passed pawn on
d4 and on f4 Knights the d3 Fabi
establishes a blockade against the d4
pawn and also is now ready to capture on
f4 so holidays on out brings
yet another defender to the f4 pawn and
here both players are now on 30 minutes
on the clock
so both of them taking care of their
time we have looked the f3 by Fabi now
adding a defender to the h3 pawn but
also
maybe looking at bringing the rook to f1
and again going after the f4 pawn so
here I live as a g5 pieces okay this
pawn is now nicely protected there's no
there's no grabbing that pawn and here
father plays rook the g1 puts the rook
in front of the king so what do you play
here it's a very important moment in the
game feel free to pause the video and
find a move for ali reza while i give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
king site expanding move and for those
who just want to enjoy the show best
here for black is h5 which prevents Fabi
from ever executing this h4 idea as you
will just have this set up and now it's
it's probably black with who's winning
but instead after rook to g1 ali reza
immediately played King to f8 and now he
allowed Fabi this age for breakthrough
which is which is huge for Fabi as he's
fighting against all of these pawns and
this just well allowing him to open up
files for his rook is is well could be
too much so here of course you cannot
push because the chief you don't you do
not have upon an H 5 to help you cover
g4 square so h6 by allah reza now h
captures h captures and the now rook the
h3 so yes sorry rook the rook the h3 so
yes ali reza does have two connected
pass pawns and he does have a passed
deep on but he might have some problems
problems defending so here we have f3
it's possible as the g5 point is nicely
guarded it's attacked twice but it's
also guarded twice by the knight and the
Queen and here Bishop to c4
now Fabi wants to eliminate one of the
defenders of of the g5 pawn and here
King the king that East 7 is played by
ali reza there is no way to add more
protection to the pawn since let's say
if you try this rook f1 you're just
gonna lose this pawn
there's no way to add another defender
to this one so like i said even if even
though it's too connected pawns here I
pass deep on it's easy to pick them off
so
that's what fob is plan is King to e7 by
Allah Reza it will be the king is safer
there for the moment but Bishop captures
on e6 and now how do you capture that
problem with capturing with the pawn and
sort of creating a very strong center
here is white can immediately upon if
you rook to h7 check King f8 and now
Queen to h2 so what what do you play
here for example if F - you just think
well you can just even capture it and if
rook captures now you have this rook to
e8 check came to e7 and now Queen to c7
check rugby seven blocks rook to h7 adds
another attacker to the rook and now
after King f8 you will just capture here
and there is no defense against mate
even if you trade here captures captures
King goes here there's no Queen Queen c4
check to go for some sort of a perpetual
because the Queen covers it and the next
is just well next is just mate so
capturing with the F pawn is not
possible even though it would be great
if you could get this point going down
the board so King captures an e6 by ali
reza and now queen queen to h2 which
creates a lot of threats here well first
one of course rook to h6 just winning
the queen so if we try it if you try
running well it's the king bee 7 then
again rook h6 if the Queen moves away
from the control of the d6 square and
the Queen lands on these six death just
over so let's say Queen e7 but now look
the c1 again threatening Queen here or
look here and just picking up the Queen
rook to see it and now rook to e1 and
this is just game as now you cannot use
any of these squares to keep an eye on
the d6 square and if you move to a fate
to still do it than just Queen to h3
wins the rook there's no way to defend
it as it's pinned so after this Queen th
to move and this threat Alireza tries f2
and now hoping that okay fruit to h6 I
always have this a very nice capture but
the Fabi just plays rook to f1 that's
why I showed the other line as that
there was no way to avoid this you have
to give up the f2 pawn so King d7 now
and now again a rook h6 Fabi goes after
this after this line Queen to e7
and now rook captures an f2 there is no
reason not to capture this pawn with
well rook captures an f2 Queen captures
an f2 and now it's moved 39 Alireza
needs to make one more move to reach
time control he goes King to c8 hoping
to escape with the king and now he does
have a room behind the passed pawn but
still it's unlikely that you will be
able to get rid of this blockade so Fabi
goes a5 he wants to bust open the
position capture here the roof is also
covering that b6 square B captures an 85
by Allah Reza and now Queen to c2 with
check King to b8 and now comes Knight
the sea fly with all sorts of nasty
ideas for example let's say you try f6
to keep the rock out of the game then
rook h7 the Queen guards h7 you can now
bring the rook to b7 and that's that's
just a game if we try g4 let's say you
just push up on then then you're running
into a forced checkmate with Queen to h2
check King - AAA - now Queen to h1 or G
to check you force the King back and
then now this night the a6 check only
move King to see it and then now Queen
the c6 check forces a block with the
Queen and now this is made so after
night to c5 really not a lot of moves
this Queen to h2 move check will be
deadly
so holidays are blocks with the rook
kind of hoping that Bobby still goes for
this Queen - h2 pinning move and the he
hopes to survive maybe with King to c7
but it's also losses on the spot so it's
a nice idea
so even feel free to pause the video and
try to find how it loses on the spot
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
this is one of the cases where the
strongest move is not with the knight
back but actually with the knight
forward
so here it's Knight to d7
congratulations to everyone who found
that and well you just added a third
attacker to the to the to the rook and
there there are no moves here for black
you have to capture the denied and allow
this captures and now you're just upper
rook so this is one way to go about it
but Fabio obviously trusted all the rez
on this one and he decided to go for a
different line he played rook a to a
track
we have looked at the eight blocking and
now Queen to b3 with check with King to
c7 and now comes queen - b7 check we
have King to d6 and now of course rook
to h6 check here I'll get Reza blocks
but now Knight to e4 with check and it
was in this position unmoved 48 that
Alireza fallujah resigned to the game
and Fabi takes another victory so here
you resign as well if you move the King
away from the defense of the Queen you
just lose the Queen so your only other
option is kinked East 6 which just runs
into first Knight captures an g5 with
check the pawn is pinned you go back now
to check again you go back and now just
real captures here just you know first
grabbing the g5 point for good measure
and now you force a trade so captures
captures and sorry captures and well not
with the night
you don't even win the night Queen c6
check forces the King back and now you
pick up the the Queen this way so it's
much cleaner and yes you do have room
behind the past pawn but that's besides
the point
so after Knight to e4 check another
excellent game bye-bye fuchsia against
world number 2 Fabiano Caruana also form
of roaches championship challenger and
it really the the code about the board I
believe is fitting because here it was
just well here at this moment we're
fabulous rock to g1 if h5 landed which
which really does make sense it's heart
heart
continue continue with white really just
finding a move for white is not easy and
and always and even if I mean you can
maybe even bring the King here bring the
rook over there maybe you can even start
pushing here but it's not what you want
to do but it might be an option in the
future if if white wants to push this
for more than four more than it is but
yeah he played the King to f8 instead it
just got out of the pin but then h4 just
bust open the perish position and now
the the extra piece really comes in
handy
what a a really impressive game by both
of them but that's well if you play
against Fabiano Khurana you do not give
him give him anything especially
something like King to f8 in this
position because
he will punish that so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and here I
prepared the standings as I didn't show
them in the previous round these are not
the correct standings as a lot of silver
team still didn't finish his game
against Jeffrey Xian but I believe she
had had a decent position but okay for
the top of the standings this is why why
I'm showing it so Fabiano is now in the
so lead with seven out of ten followed
by Magnus Carlsen then Wesley so with
six Jurgen one forest with six out of
ten and then I don't know if the others
are correct since our team even four and
a half and he might win against young so
the the table you know the score sheet
might shift but here for the for the top
Fabiana karana after 10 rounds so leader
of the tata steel master solution 2020
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank land Salish that
phillips right son now Asif Kapadia lens
Gibbons and the John a better year for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata Steel masters
edition checking up on the Women's World
Chess Championship match there's only
one more game left and of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day